household debt has absolutely exploded
in this country household debt rose 313
billion dollars in q2 to nearly 15
trillion dollars
debt is
exploding now why is household debt
exploding a lot of it has to do with the
items that you normally take on debt to
purchase continue to increase in price
house prices have exploded car prices
have exploded and so for those items
that you normally would go get a car
loan or a mortgage for if they are
increasing in price you have to take on
more and more and more debt in order to
be able to afford the actual purchase
and so when we went we looked at
all of the different charts
this might be the most aggressive chart
accumulation that we've ever had the
best business show research team put it
together so let's just start with the
u.s household debt balance
if we look at the actual debt balance
from kind of pre-2004 until now what we
are seeing is everything is moving up
and to the right
mortgages helps auto loans credit cards
student loans every everything is up and
to the right we are hitting all-time
highs in debt in this country household
debt continues to rise coming out of
that 2007 2008 crisis you can see where
there was a rise people started to pay
down the debt going into 2012 13 14 15
and then it started to take off again
and it has not stopped if we then look
at the non-payers people who have
supportive policy measures continuing to
limit delinquency transaction rates all
this means is that the government
programs we're putting money into
people's hands and allowing them to pay
off their payments so that or not maybe
not pay off the entire payment but be
able to pay some of the payments so that
they weren't delinquent this is a good
thing the fact that there was less
delinquency the fact that they had more
money in their pockets to be able to pay
this stuff that is one positive impact
of those programs was the government was
basically handing out money to people
they were taking that money and they
were paying off their credit card
they're paying off their mortgages they
were paying all these different things
that is important but then if we look at
the actual breakdown of where is the
debt surging where is the actual change
in various types of debt you can see
that mortgages by far are seeing the
largest increase
seven percent now point seven percent
doesn't sound like it's that big of a
number except for when you think about
mortgage debt alone in the united states
is now
over 10 trillion dollars think about
that for a second student loans as an
example or a comparison is about 1.5 1.6
trillion dollars so literally mortgages
are more than five six times as much as
student loans makes sense but 10
trillion dollars and annually increasing
0.7
that is a big big number now we do see
some numbers coming down like credit
cards uh or other but overall we
continue to see the debt in america
skyrocket when we look at auto loans and
leases you can see very clearly that we
are just on a
tear
we're going to continue to grow to the
sky the auto loan and lease market
has no chill there is no chill going on
here why do we see such aggressive
appreciation and kind of collection of
auto loans and leases in the united
states 1.4 trillion there's almost as
much auto loans as there are student
loans in america why
the cost of cars especially used cars
continues to rise if we remember a
couple of episodes ago we talked about
the used car index is up 50 percent five
zero percent and so naturally if you
want to buy one of those cars you need a
loan you have to take on more debt in
order to buy that same exact car that is
driving a lot of this auto loans and
leases
credit cards are another form of debt
that most people are used to looking at
credit cards have actually been coming
down which is a good thing you can see
that coming out of the 2007-2008 crisis
a lot of payment down of debt all the
way to kind of uh local lows in 2012 13
and 14 and then we went back up now
we're coming back down now what we like
to see is remember the average balance
uh in america on a credit card six
thousand dollars and the average
interest rate 16 17 percent getting that
down is important and so seeing 2020
continuing people to pay off those
credit cards or pay down those credit
cards is really important but you know
what's not going down student loans we
talked about it earlier there's almost
as much car loans in america as there
are student loans the student loan
balance continues to drive upwards at a
45 degree angle like nothing can stop it
it does not matter if there's crisis it
does not matter if there's economic
booms it does not matter about anything
the relentless student loan balance
continues to
explode
this chart to me is the scariest thing
in the world
all we have watched since 2003 is an
absolute 45 degree angle increase in the
student loan balance and it's not going
to stop any time soon
other consumer debt balances they
dropped significantly coming out of
2007-2008 crisis but they have
rapidly recovered and we've basically
gone sideways through the pandemic and
so when you see this type of rapid
appreciation from 2013
and then moving sideways what it tells
you is that people are not paying it
down and then lastly you can see here
the mortgage balances themselves uh
about 10.5 trillion dollars in mortgages
and what is really fascinating is you
can see that the mortgage balances in
2006 2007 2008 were at kind of a local
high we then got people paying it down
and then we've been on absolute tear one
of the things that scares the hell out
of me about these charts is that today
we sit at about 10.5 trillion dollars of
mortgage balances which is much higher
right more than 10 percent higher than
we were during the housing bubble if the
housing bubble was only nine nine and a
half trillion but today we are at ten
and a half trillion maybe we should be
thinking about why we called that a
bubble and not this and then lastly the
distribution of credit scores for new
mortgages you can see here that
basically if you have a median score
close to 800 a high median score then
you get a new mortgage but the lower and
lower you get the harder it gets to
actually get a mortgage but the credit
score you need to get a new mortgage
continues to move upward right seeing
that upward movement means that the
overall credit needed for a mortgage
continues to improve
so
when we think about this the last thing
is
bankruptcy shouldn't bankruptcy filings
if debt is increasing be exploding
but in a shocking way last year there
was tons of bankruptcy filings in 2021
so far
it's actually looks like we may beat it
it's gonna be close there was an
explosion of bankruptcy filings
last year
but the fewest large bankruptcy filings
so far we are on pace for
today
it's pretty crazy what do you guys think
about this it just seems like debt is
just taking off and it's not going to
stop anytime soon people are going to
continue to take on the debt yeah but i
think it makes sense when you think
about everything in uh kind of in
combination of each other right so
credit card balances fell pretty
dramatically over uh kovid which makes
sense right people were getting stimulus
checks uh they couldn't necessarily go
out you're not going to restaurants you
couldn't go to these places so you're
incentivized to save money personal
savings accounts reached all time highs
i believe during the pandemic but then
uh mortgages so like it's easy to kind
of just look at the chart and get lost
in the numbers but
the uh mortgage balances are at over 10
trillion dollars right now 4.4 trillion
44 of it was added in the last year so
part of that is obviously uh refinances
people seeing these lower rates and
going and refinancing and stuff like
that but then part of it is just the uh
it really shows the cost of these homes
now right so as the price of homes
increase uh when people go to get new
mortgages that's where that shows up
right it shows up in the debt of uh or
the balance of the mortgages that they
get the more expense of the house the
larger the mortgage you have to to take
on so i think when you think about it in
totality yeah
auto loans are up to 1.1 trillion which
is a staggering amount when you would
have looked at it a few years ago but in
the context that mortgages rose 4.4
trillion like that's crazy
the part to me uh should we be surprised
student loans and car loans are almost
equal
about 1.5 trillion each like does that
surprise you
yeah because when you think about it
like the the student loans chart uh it
moves kind of at a regular interval
every year right so like there's kind of
a certain percentage of fixed percentage
you can call it that of people that are
going to school each year maybe that
number increases whatever the percent is
say it's two three four five whatever uh
it's increasing at a steady rate over
time so there's no huge uh you know drop
drop off or gain necessarily each year
so covey didn't necessarily have a
massive impact on the student loan
balances as opposed to the other charts
you look at and there's a massive
drop-off in credit card balances but
then there's a massive uptick in
mortgages and car loans and all these
things college didn't necessarily get 10
times more expensive or 10 more
expensive or 15 more expensive like cars
did right so the combination of people
going to buy cars drives the price up
and then when you go get a loan on the
car that loan is now more expensive and
you're taking on more debt to pay it it
makes sense i guess it's just uh
the number of people taking out student
loans versus the number of people who
own cars
right if you think of it from that
standpoint there should be more car
owners than college students yeah but
the cost is probably less the cost is
you know what uh the average
car loan what's the average car loan uh
in america my guess is that it's
probably somewhere between ten to twenty
thousand dollars if i had to guess uh
and if you think of the average college
loan it's gotta be
forty fifty thousand dollars right so so
in some case it could be as much as two
to four times as big uh if i had to
guess but i'm not sure john what do you
think
these charts look like a roller coaster
it's ridiculous i mean you look at the
auto loans chart and it's up it goes
back down once people hit a financial
hardship to the uh the housing crisis
and stuff like that and
i can't i keep coming back to the
thought of if we're in a housing bubble
right now if that's what we're seeing
because there were more fundamental
issues with the 2007-2008
housing crash right the subprime
mortgages and you see i think the
average credit score now to get a
mortgage origination is like 760. so
very high mortgage you're more likely to
pay it back but
i mean you look at these charts it looks
the exact same so the average loan
amount is actually it's a little higher
than i would have expected the average
loan amount for a new car is 34 000
and the average uh loan amount for a
used car is twenty one thousand dollars
oh damn it's on the higher end get out
of debt so they say
well so they talk about uh and that is
slightly lower than what it would cost
on the used car side uh for a bachelor
degree the average loan taken out on
that side is 29 000 so about eight
thousand dollars less for used cars but
then you don't take into account uh law
school debt is 145 000
mba debt is 66 000 so what is a student
loan like that just regular college 29
000. so about eight thousand dollars
more than a usual wow that that's way
lower than i would have thought yeah
public colleges well yeah there's
yeah well public university definitely
is cheaper but still if you think about
the average well there's federal
subsidies too yeah there's a bunch of
things playing but
it's still uh i think i was more
surprised about auto loans being 21 000
1 000 for a used car is the average
yeah that's nuts and then i guess also
part of this is uh we were talking
yesterday about like the buy now pay
later programs uh pretty much there's
none of that right going on uh here and
so you have to take on debt uh and when
you think about some of these
uh debt that you're actually taking the
explosion of debt in the united states
like household consumer debt mortgages
and cars uh i believe are some of the
more expensive uh loans that you can
actually take right so credit card debt
obviously is the most expensive but
credit card debt's actually been coming
down in terms of uh the annual percent
change people pay off uh some of the
credit cards there but auto loans uh
going up student loans going up uh but
mortgages being the the greatest
contributor to me this what this shows
you here is it's all being pulled up by
mortgages and the mortgage rates uh
while they may not be the most expensive
they're still pretty high uh from a
carrying cost and so what does is it
pushes people much much further like if
you have an average balance of six
thousand dollars and you're paying you
know 16 for example you're basically
paying let's call it you know somewhere
around a thousand bucks hey guys thanks
so much for watching that clip of the
best business show make sure you like
and subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it